bias affects virtually every aspect of
the statistics and data science realms
keep watching and we're gonna break down
all the different types of statistical
bias that you need to be aware of
I'm Richard this is Richard on data they
say sometimes in data science and
statistics that your goal is to reduce
variance however bias is another type of
error that occurs and often times it can
be just as serious in fact the trade-off
between bias and variance is one of the
most important concepts in the machine
learning universe but that's largely a
subject for a different video so there
are seven different types of bias that
we're gonna discuss here and those are
selection bias recall bias observer bias
survivorship bias omitted variable bias
sponsorship bias and cause-and-effect
bias before we get into all these I
would humbly ask that if you haven't
already please subscribe to this channel
and also take one second to smash the
like button because that really does
help my content reach a larger audience
and I'm also on patreon if you would
like to support my work that way as well
so first and foremost with selection
bias this is probably the type that the
most people are at least somewhat
familiar with and this is the
circumstance in which not all people in
the study have the same probability of
being selected and there are a number of
reasons why this can occur one
particularly common reason is because of
sampling bias so for instance if you're
doing any kind of non-random sampling
like convenience sampling by definition
not everybody has the same chance of
being selected one type of selection
bias is confirmation bias this is
probably everybody's favorite that's
when you tend to utilize and favor
certain information that confirms your
own pre-existing notions and my personal
favorite example of this is Twitter so
if you go on there expecting that what
you see is going to represent public
opinion on virtually any topic most of
the time think again because you have a
sample on there that's
disproportionately very young and
disproportionately of the type of
personality that likes to go on Twitter
and
sweet things next up we have recall bias
which is the phenomenon where subjects
will remember things that happen more
recently pretty well but their memory
fades the further back you go in the
past now this is an interesting one
because scientists do think that human
memory functions sort of like a
telephone game that is when you remember
something that happens in the past
technically you are remembering the last
time that you remembered it so over time
the accuracy of your memory becomes less
and less and less it's also said that
people tend to look at the past through
rose-colored glasses that awesome
wedding that you went to a couple years
ago yeah at the time you thought it was
awful and you couldn't wait to go back
to your hotel room and sleep admit it
next up we have observer bias and this
gets to the fact that a lot of data that
we collect are just things we observe in
nature in general are filtered through
the lens of human subjectivity a lot of
data had to be collected and measured by
somebody and in fact sometimes that
measurement is subjective and it could
vary from person to person this is
especially the case when researchers are
working together on something because
they can't influence each other's
opinions and findings in ways that would
not happen if they were working
independently this is partly the
foundation for doing blinded studies
that is the participant doesn't know
what kind of treatment they've received
the reason for that is some people they
may get a placebo drug and they start to
get better because their brain is
telling them they're going to get better
because they're on the drug when really
all they're experiencing is the placebo
effect
well the placebo effect is an example of
observer bias and there's also a related
phenomenon known as the Hawthorne effect
this is a really well-known effect where
people behave much differently when they
know they're being observed like that
time your boss was behind your shoulder
watching you work then they went away
and then you immediately spent ten
minutes looking at your Instagram feed
you know who you are next up is
survivorship bias and this is a
lesser-known one that's technically a
form of selection
bias but this is a special case where
the things you observe can only be
observed after coming through some long
selection process that's survivorship
will affect who's in your sample and
often those who make it through the
process and those who don't are
systematically different in some sort of
way hence you've got a bias my favorite
example of this is from World War two
and it's when the statistician Abraham
Wald was involved in figuring out how do
we reduce the number of bombers we have
that are shot down by enemy fire
so they observed planes when they came
back from missions and it was found
there were certain parts of the plane
that were full holes and certain parts
of the plane with no holes whatsoever so
Wald proposed let's put armor on the
parts of the plane with no holes that
were seeing well it turns out that if
planes were shot in that area that
nobody was seeing any holes in the plane
wasn't coming back at all it would have
been shot down
whereas this area of the plane that was
being shot at adding armor wouldn't help
because all the planes that were shot
there eventually made it back so this is
a very famous and clever realization of
survivorship bias next up is omitted
variable bias and this one is related to
the very famous curse of dimensionality
that is if you fit your model with too
many variables it tends not to
generalize very well outside of the data
it was trained on that is it over fits
and it has high variance well the
opposite of that is true too if you're
omitting certain important variables the
model under fits and it has a bias
essentially what ends up happening is
effects that should be attributed to the
important variables become attributed to
the variables which aren't truthfully as
important and whether you have bias or
variance in your model you're going to
end up making incorrect or incomplete
inferences and your model is not going
to perform as well on a test set if your
goal happens to be prediction next we
have sponsorship bias and one of the
overall most important questions that
comes with interpreting any statistical
study and that is
who's paying for it this is something
that I think far too often gets
completely forgotten and that's that
scientists are not dispassionate and
careless observers of the truth
there will always be a bias in favor of
the financial sponsors of a study and
there's also a publication bias that is
extreme results are far more likely to
get published than well we looked at
this vitamin to figure out if it cures
cancer turns out it doesn't we talked
about blinded studies as a way of
reducing observer bias but also we can
have double blinded studies where
neither the participants nor the
researchers know the real treatment
regimen that's going on that way we can
reduce both observer bias as well as
sponsorship bias or any other biases
that the researchers may suffer from
themselves and then one last bias that's
rarely mentioned is what's known as
cause effect bias now I'm gonna do a
whole video series at some point about
causal inference because it's truly a
very rich topic but the long and the
short of it is humans like to assume a
cause exists even if we haven't
demonstrated that it does as the old
adage goes correlation does not imply
causation when we observe a relationship
between two variables x and y it could
be the X causes Y it could also be the
case Y causes X oftentimes what's really
happening is some variable Z is causing
both x and y alternatively the
relationship could be more cyclical that
is X causes Y then Y causes X in turn
causing more of Y and so on and so forth
or the relationship between x and y
could be purely due to chance and
coincidence either way you cannot jump
to assuming that X causes Y so this is
just an overview of the most common
types of statistical bias but one thing
to keep in mind is that there are times
when it makes sense to accept a little
bit of bias with the goal of reducing
variants thus reducing all overall error
but again that's a subject for a
different video it is worth asking
yourself during all stages of
statistical analysis and data science
does bias exist
anywhere here and then if it does how
does it influence my results and can
anything be done about it
so thanks for watching this video if you
enjoyed it and you would like to support
my work one of the most helpful things
that you could do for me would be to
share this video otherwise at least
consider hitting the like button and
also leave me a comment down below and
let me know what kinds of biases that
you've encountered during your data
science journey then I'll see you all in
the not so distant future until then
Richard on data